I was so excited to have you on the show
but I know you already actually know
Megan right this is this is the drinkie
family by the way but you already know
anyway I haven't seen you in so long
I know you look amazing thank you you
look great thank you
yeah Megan and I we met a long time ago
on the show I was on called undateable
and came and we have fun we hit it off
and she gave me her number and so let's
hang out and just talk and chat and I
called her and it just went doo doo doo
[Applause]
so I've been waiting to see the number I
gave you is totally gonna work just keep
calling it yeah my phone number has
changed three times this isn't a lie dad
papa stand up for me I had to change my
number at least three times so I yeah I
never got a call that was so rude Ron
okay
I heard you started singing lessons that
I did yeah because I've been doing a lot
of voiceovers and cartoons we're both in
the trolls do you have a singing a lot
Angela and singing as a cartoon voice
and I'm like I can't sing regularly yeah
why are you trying to make me sing as a
giraffe that's great it probably sounds
really fun yeah that good longer throat
long-guns velvety boys but I was like
let me get some singing lessons in
because I think that's the only thing I
miss and I'm already hilarious I'm
already very hand
[Applause]
yeah can I become a triple threat and
then you know justjust just take over
the world I love it well I feel like
your dreams are gonna become a reality
because you you're really into something
that helps those dreams come in reality
right I am big into lately I've been big
into making what I call vision boards
dream board yeah yeah well we made
notebooks we cut out newspaper articles
and magazine pictures and made notebooks
for our travels head on there I went to
Australia and I did comedy there in
April that happened I'm going to Japan
and in December hopefully I'm gonna get
a baby that's my new baby committed and
everything my acting my comedy my
girlfriend just trying to stay committed
that's that's beautiful but I do
question you have not one but three
pictures yes what does this mean what is
your point I mean I love the rock - it's
just on your vision board that's cool
yeah I love the rock you want to eat it
he is the epitome of what a man should
be to me here perfect he is amazing he's
a leader he is basically the Beyonce for
boys
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay and so if he on your vision board
cuz you want to work with him I want to
work with him I want to be like him I
want him to carry me ye ice-cream okay
but you've accomplished right you said
you've been to Australia going to Japan
the end of the year where's your there
other vision board that's why I was so
excited about I got so much stuff done
we're only about halfway through the
year yeah I got I started adding to my
vision you didn't even answer the phone
but you made it that's why she's into
porn that's amazing you're gonna sing
and play with us yeah we're gonna sand
off into the sunset
absolutely deal and you're reading a
book thank you you're very very talented
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this